Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. TD Direct Investing offers live support, so whether you're a newbie or a seasoned pro, you can make your investing steps count. And if you're like me and think a TFSA stands for Total Fund Savings Adventure, maybe reach out to TD Direct Investing. The homeland will be saved. Everything is in motion. Everyone burns to fight.
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。要想获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听特权，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。TD Direct Investing 提供实时客服支持，因此无论你是新手还是老手，都能让你的每一步投资都算数。如果你和我一样，认为 TFSA 代表的是“全基金储蓄大冒险”（Total Fund Savings Adventure），或许可以联系一下 TD Direct Investing。祖国将被拯救。一切都在运转。每个人都渴望战斗。
While one part of the people goes for the frontiers, a second digs our defenses, and a third, armed with pikes, will defend our cities and towns. We ask that whoever refuses to serve or to give up his weapons shall be punished with death. The toxin that will ring out will not be a signal of alarm, but a call to charge against the enemies of the homeland. To vanquish them, gentlemen, we need to dare, to dare, and to dare again, and then France will be saved. So that Dominic was not Winston Churchill, although many people from the excellence of
一部分人奔赴前线，第二部分人挖掘防御工事，第三部分手持长矛，将保卫我们的城市和城镇。我们要求，任何拒绝服兵役或交出武器的人都将被处以死刑。即将鸣响的警钟，将不再是警报信号，而是对祖国敌人的冲锋号角。为了击败他们，先生们，我们需要大胆，大胆，再大胆，然后法国就会拯救。因此，多米尼克不是温斯顿·丘吉尔，尽管许多人从他那出色的
the impression may think it was. It was actually a Frenchman. George Danton, minister of justice in 1792, the Dominic Sandbrook to my Robespierre. Oh, that's kind. Thanks Tom. And he's addressing the assembly on the 2nd of September, 1792. And people will be able to realize from this that we are back with the French revolution. We are indeed Tom.
表现中可能会认为是。他其实是个法国人。乔治·丹东，1792 年的司法部长，我这位罗伯斯庇尔的多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。哦，你真好。谢谢汤姆。他在 1792 年 9 月 2 日向国民议会发表讲话。通过这一点，大家会意识到我们又回到了法国大革命。我们确实回来了，汤姆。
Our ongoing series, aren't we? And can I just say why I chose to do it in a Churchillian tone? Do, yeah, please. Because I think there is a Churchillian quality to that, isn't it? That is a very, very famous speech. It's all about defense of the fatherland, defense of the nation, determination to fight on, and there is a Churchillian quality to it. And I thought it subtly evoked a sense for British listeners of perhaps the resonance
我们正在播出的系列节目，不是吗？我能说一下我为什么选择用丘吉尔式的语调来表达吗？请说，请吧。因为我认为其中有一种丘吉尔式的特质，不是吗？那是一场非常非常著名的演讲。内容全关于保卫祖国、保卫国家、战斗到底的决心，其中蕴含着一种丘吉尔式的特质。我原以为这会微妙地唤起英国听众对它在法国可能产生的共鸣的一种感觉
it has in France. Yeah, it does have a huge resonance in France. So those words in French, il nous faut de l'audace, encore de l'audace, toujours de l'audace. We need daring, more daring, always daring, to dare, to dare, to dare again, or however you translate it. They're very famous. Lots of French school children will know those words.
是的，它在法国确实引起了巨大的共鸣。因此，法语中的那些词是：il nous faut de l'audace, encore de l'audace, toujours de l'audace。我们需要勇气，更多的勇气，永远的勇气，去大胆，大胆，再大胆，无论你如何翻译它们。它们非常著名。许多法国小学生都会知道这些词。
And that, I think, gives you a sense of the position that we're in as we begin season three of the French Revolution. This episode is very, very gory. So listeners should be warned. It is absolutely revolting, particularly if you have children be warned. Because in today's episode, we will be turning to, I would say, perhaps the most horrific episode of the whole revolution, the September massacres. So to give people a sense, this is a moment when mobs are going to storm,
我认为，这让你对我们开始法国大革命第三季时的处境有了一个直观的感受。这一集非常非常血腥。所以应该对听众发出警告。这绝对令人作呕，特别是如果你有孩子的话，更要引以为戒。因为在今天的节目中，我们将转向整场革命中最惨绝人寰的一幕——九月大屠杀。为了让大家有个概念，这是一个暴徒们将要冲进监狱的时刻，
basically burst into the prisons. Or are they mobs? I mean, we'll be discussing, won't we? Mobs or death squads. Or are they mobs? I mean, we'll be discussing, won't we? Mobs or death squads. And they are going to club or hack a thousand people to death. Some of them in very gruesome circumstances. And we'll be debating all that later, but Tom, perhaps first of all, we should remind people where we have got to now. Obviously by reminding people we don't need to do the whole previous two series again.
基本上是强行闯入。或者说他们是暴徒吗？我的意思是，我们接下来会讨论，对吧？是暴徒还是突击队？或者说他们是暴徒吗？我的意思是，我们接下来会讨论，对吧？是暴徒还是突击队？他们将用棍棒或砍刀将一千人殴打致死。其中一些人的死状极其惨烈。我们稍后将对这一切进行辩论，但汤姆，也许首先，我们应该提醒大家我们现在讲到哪里了。当然，提醒大家并不意味着我们要把前两个系列的内容重新讲一遍。
That would be too meta. But yeah, it would. We'd never get out of it. Okay, to give people a sense, we're in 1792. Tuileries has been stormed. France is at war and it's been at war since April and it's gone incredibly badly so far. So France has basically lost, there's little battles. So politics in Paris is defined by a feud between two rival groups of Jacob.
那未免太形而上了。不过是的，确实如此。那样我们就永远走不出来了。好吧，为了让大家有个概念，我们正处于 1792 年。杜伊勒里宫遭到强攻。法国已经处于战争状态，而且自四月以来就一直在打仗，目前为止进展极为糟糕。所以法国基本上输了，只有一些小规模战斗。因此，巴黎的政治是由两派激进分子的残酷争斗所决定的。
So the first faction, according to Jiranda and they're under Briceau, who you really liked as I recall. Like Briceau. Yeah. Yeah. That's Briceau, isn't he? He's an abolitionist. He likes a literary salon.
所以第一派，根据吉伦特派的说法，他们是由布里索领导的，正如我所记得的那样，你真的很喜欢他。喜欢布里索。是的。是的。那是布里索，对吧？他是个废奴主义者。他喜欢文学沙龙。
Yeah. He likes dinner with metropolitan people. He's a good man. Yeah, that's that's Briceau. And then on the other end, another very Tom Holland figure actually. Yeah. It's like the battle for your soul this time. This is why I find it so fascinating.
是的。他喜欢与大都市里的人共进晚餐。他是个好人。是的，那就是布里索。而在另一端，则是另一个非常具有汤姆·霍兰德特质的人物。是的。这就像是这次为了你的灵魂而战。这就是为什么我觉得它如此迷人。
It's the Montagnard, the mountain as they're called under Maximilien Crobisbierre, the kind of bony, Rousseau loving. Another do-gooder. Bewigged. Yeah, bewigged do-gooder. Hates capital punishment. Yeah, like you. The streets of Paris are full of armed young men.
他们是山岳派，正如他们被称为山岳派的那样，在马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔的领导下，那种骨瘦如柴、热爱卢梭的人。又一个好管闲事的人。戴着假发。是的，戴着假发的爱管闲事的人。痛恨死刑。是的，就像你一样。巴黎街头到处都是手持武器的年轻男子。
So these are the Federer from Marseille and elsewhere. Tom, last time you talked about their importance in bringing the Marseillais. That was the episode that we finished the last season on. It was indeed. And people will remember that the episode before that was the story of how these guys, the Federer and the soncoulotte on the streets of Paris, the people who wear trousers, the kind of artisans, the radicals, they stormed the Tuileries Palace, they launched a second revolution, they slaughtered the Swiss Guard,
这些人是来自马赛及其他地方的联邦兵。汤姆，上次你谈到了他们带兵马赛曲时的重要性。那就是我们结束上一季的那一集。确实如此。大家会记得，再上一集讲的是这些人——巴黎街头的联邦兵和无套裤汉，那些穿裤子的平民、工匠和激进分子——他们攻占了杜伊勒里宫，发动了第二次革命，屠杀了瑞士卫队，
they effectively toppled the King and Queen who'd been carted off to a prison called the Temple Fortress, but they also crucially arrested about a thousand people who have since been crammed into the prisons of Paris. Will Barron This is a key point, isn't it? Because it's important to emphasize that although it's the Swiss guards who end up being massacred, the opinion across Paris, particularly among the sans-culottes, is that they were the victims. Adam Felsen Exactly right. Will Barron That it was the Swiss Guard who had to blame for it, that the working people of Paris who
他们实际上推翻了国王和王后，国王和王后被押送到一个叫圣殿堡垒的监狱里，但更关键的是，他们还逮捕了大约一千人，这些人后来被塞满了巴黎的监狱。威廉·巴伦 这是一个关键点，不是吗？因为强调这一点很重要，尽管最终被大屠杀的是瑞士卫队，但整个巴黎的舆论，特别是无套裤汉当中的舆论，认为他们才是受害者。亚瑟·费尔森 完全正确。威廉·巴伦 认为应该对这一切负责的是瑞士卫队，巴黎的劳动人民在保卫自己的同时被瑞士卫队杀害，他们是自由的殉道者，这表现了一种顽固的保王派对法国大众的恶劣态度。因此，公民有必要保持警惕，防止类似事件再次发生。因此，公民有必要保持警惕，防止类似事件再次发生。完全正确。这绝对正确。所以为了让大家对政治有个概念，随着杜伊勒里宫的攻陷，政治
were killed by the Swiss Guards as they were defending themselves are martyrs to liberty, and that this is expressive of a kind of pernicious royal attitude to the French masses. And therefore, there is a need for citizens to be on guard against something like this happening again. Therefore, there is a need for citizens to be on guard against something like this happening again. Exactly right. That's exactly right. So to give people a sense of the politics, with the stormy of the Tuileries, politics
陷入了彻底的混乱。国王和他的家人在圣殿里。取而代之的是，立法议会成立了这个行政机构，主要由吉伦特派和司法部长丹东主导。他们说，听着，我们不得不进行又一次宪政重启。我们要召开国民公会。现在这将是第一次在近乎普遍的成年男性普选权下选举产生。
have been plunged into total chaos. The king and his family are in the temple. In their place, the Legislative Assembly has set up this executive, which is basically dominated by the Girondins and by Danton, Minister of Justice. And they have said, listen, we are going to have to have yet another constitutional kind of reboot. We're going to call for a national convention. Now this will be elected for the first time in near universal male suffrage.
每个人都知道这基本上是在呼吁建立共和国，君主制已经完结了。但是吉伦特派主导了这个委员会并真正主导了议会，看起来他们已经掌握了一切，但事实并非如此，因为现在他们必须在巴黎与这个新成立的机构——起义公社——分享权力，这是一个更激进的人群，特别是罗伯斯庇尔所主导的本地议会。
And everybody knows this is basically going to call for a republic, that the monarchy is finished. But the Girondins who dominate this committee and who really dominate the assembly, it looks like they've got everything their own way, but they don't because now they're having to kind of share power in Paris with this new body that's been set up called the insurrectionary commune, which is kind of the local council, which is dominated by much more radical people and in particular
如果这一切还不够令人困惑的话，罗伯斯庇尔说，把我们拖入战争的吉伦特派，实际上实在是太软弱、太温和了。他们对王室和内部敌人太温和了，他们实际上可能是外国阴谋的一部分，这听起来太疯狂了，但这也让你对 1792 年这个时期存在的派系斗争和偏见有了个概念。我认为人们其实有一个很容易理解这一点的方法，因为这是“左翼”和“右翼”概念引入的时期，因为这取决于
by Robespierre. And if all this isn't confusing enough, Robespierre says the Girondins, who are the people who got us into the war, they're actually much too weak and too soft. They've been much too soft on the royal family and on the enemies within, and they may actually be part of the foreign conspiracy, which sounds bonkers, but that gives you a sense of the kind of the faction fighting, the paranoia that is around in this point in 1792. I think there is actually quite an easy way for people to get a handle on this, because this is the period where the notion of right and left comes in, because it depends on
人们在国民议会中的聚集地点。正如我们以时代错置的方式所说的那样，极右翼是三四年前就存在的默认立场：保王派。然后是那些一直试图与保王派以及国王和王后进行谈判的革命者。然后是吉伦特派。而在极左翼，则是罗伯斯庇尔派、山岳派。我认为这可能是理解所有这些不同派系所在位置的最简单的方法。他们现在处于一个我们 21 世纪的人能够认出来的政治光谱上。是的，虽然实际上你可以认为这场斗争是在两个左翼集团之间进行的。
where people congregate in the National Assembly. And people on the far right, as we might anachronistically put it, is the default position that had existed three or four years before, royalists. Then you have revolutionaries who have been trying to negotiate with the royalists and with the king and queen. Then you have the Girondins. And then on the hard left, you have the Rospieres, the Montagnards. And I think that's probably the easiest way to kind of get a sense of where all these various factions are. They are now on a political spectrum that we in the 21st century can recognise. Yeah, although really actually you could argue that the fight is between two left-wing groups.
确实是的，因为随着君主制的倒台，右翼现在已经结束了。所以现在这是左翼和极左翼之间的战斗，你可以这样说。是的，我想你可以这么说。非常重要的是要说，巴黎的气氛被恐惧以及对即将到来的灾难和末日的预感所笼罩，因为普鲁士人一直在越境。他们正在向西挺进，普鲁士指挥官不伦瑞克公爵发表了一份宣言，其中明确表示将对巴黎人民进行报复。巴黎不在火线上。我来找你们了，而且你知道我基本上要彻底消灭你们。因此，这就是丹东表现出的丘吉尔式的挑衅特质，公然反抗德国的入侵。是的，完全如此。整个巴黎到处都是这种疯狂的谣言。人们说有大量的贵族藏在下水道里，
It is, yeah, because the right is now, with the fall of the monarchy, is finished. So it's now a fight between the left and the hard left, you might put it like that. Yes, I guess you could make that point. And it's really important to say the atmosphere in Paris is haunted by fear and by a sense of coming catastrophe and apocalypse because all the time the Prussians they've crossed the border. They're coming west and the Duke of Brunswick the Prussian commander has issued a manifesto in which he says explicitly there will be an exemplary vengeance against the people of Paris. Paris isn't the firing line. I'm coming for you and you know I'm basically going to wipe the floor with you. So this is hence the the Churchillian quality of of Danton's defiance, defying the German invasion. Yeah exactly so exactly and all through Paris there are these mad rumors. People are saying there are loads of noblemen hiding in the sewers and they're
他们准备发起袭击。他们在教堂和万神殿里藏匿了武器缓存，特别是一个谣言是巴黎监狱里的罪犯将要越狱。他们将发起暴动。他们与这些外国恶棍勾结，公社、议会、被称为“区”的社区委员会，几乎昼夜不停地开会。城市夜晚灯火通明。
poised to strike. They have hidden weapons caches in churches in the pantheon and particularly one of these rumors is that there are criminals in the Paris prisons are going to break out. They're going to launch an uprising. They are in league with these foreign villains and the commune, the assembly, the neighbourhood councils, which are called the sections, they are meeting almost permanently around the clock. The city is lit up at night.
有监视委员会。街上有军队，这是一种非凡的氛围，每个人都在等待事情发生。如果我们把时间拨回到八月二十六日，一千七百九十二年八月二十六日，来自东线战场的恐怖消息传到了巴黎。普鲁士军队已经推进了七天，他们几乎没怎么抵抗就攻占了隆维要塞。隆维投降了，只剩下一个要塞，那就是凡尔登。所以这看起来像叛国。这看起来绝对像叛国。并且看起来普鲁士人势不可挡。这时候一些宪兵说，听着，你知道的，实际上这就像是 1940 年。我们需要把政府撤退到图尔。这是一个糟糕的决定，对政府来说是一个致命的决定。撤退到图尔。这是一个糟糕的决定，
There are surveillance committees. There are troops in the streets it is an extraordinary atmosphere everybody is waiting for something to happen if we pick up the story in the twenty sixth of august twenty six will seventy ninety two terrible news reaches paris from the eastern front. The prussians have been advancing for seven days and they have just taken the fortress at Longuey after barely a fight. Longuey is surrendered and there's only one fortress left, which is Verdun. So it looks like treason. It looks like treason exactly. And it looks like the Prussians can't be stopped. Some of the gendarmes at this point say, listen, you know, effectively it's 1940. We need to evacuate the government to Tours. Which is a terrible, I mean a fateful decision for government to Tours. Which is a terrible,
我的意思是，对他们来说这是一个命运攸关的决定，因为图尔是一个非常偏向保王派的、笃信天主教的城市，不是吗？所以如果他们与更左翼的人进行生死搏斗，那不是一个明智的选择。是的，这看起来很软弱。好吧，这看起来像保王派。看起来他们实际上并没有投入到巴黎的保卫战中。罗伯斯庇尔说，绝不，我们应该坚守并为捍卫自由而战，当然还有司法部长，这个肥胖、腐败但极具个人魅力的革命领袖。另一个人有皮肤问题，听过我们前两季的听众可能还记得，皮肤问题贯穿了整个过程。
I mean a fateful decision for them to push because Tours is a very royalist and a bubble Catholic city isn't it? So not a sensible place for them to choose if they're in a life or death struggle with people on the on further to the left. Yeah it looks weak. Well it looks royalist. Looks like they're not invested actually in the defense of Paris. Robespierre says no way we should stand and fight in the defense of liberty and of course the Minister of Justice, this sort of big, fleshy, corrupt, but very charismatic revolutionary leader. Another man with skin problems and people who've listened to our first two seasons may remember that skin problems feature throughout this.
我认为可以说他的皮肤很糟糕，而且他喜欢收黑包。你知道的，他喜欢那种可以花在情妇身上以及种类繁多的开胃菜上的回扣。这就是丹东的行事方式。丹东基本上抓住了这个时机，他说，关闭巴黎的城门，设置路障。我需要，我需要志愿者。我到处都要招兵买市。他的个人魅力，他的丘吉尔式的个人魅力真的非常重要。我认为这起到了稳定军心的作用。
I think it's fair to say that he's got terrible skin and he's got a taste for a brown envelope. You know, he likes, he likes a backhander that he can spend on a mistress and a massive selection of starters. That's Danton's modus operandi. Danton basically seizes the moment and he says, close the city gates of Paris, put up barricades. I want, I want volunteers. I want recruiting stations everywhere. And his charisma, his Churchillian charisma is really important. I think sort of steadying the nerves.
我的意思是，他确实挺身而出迎合了这个时刻，但所有这些准备工作也有黑暗的一面，因为带有丹东的临时政府可以说是此时的亮点和官方公告。它说，是的，当心普鲁士人，但也要当心公民内部的敌人，你们胸怀叛徒，若不是他们，战斗早就结束了。你们的积极监督必定能打败他们。那么，他们所说的内部叛徒是什么意思？
I mean, he really rises to meet the moment, but there is a dark side to all these preparations because the provisional government with Danton is it's kind of leading light issues and official proclamation at this point. And it says, yeah, watch out for the Prussians, but also watch out for the enemies within citizens, you have traitors in your bosom, but for them, the fight would already be over. Your active surveillance cannot fail to defeat them. Now, what do they mean by the traitors within?
他们指的是国王腐败的前顾问、宫廷里被他们称之为女同性恋的宫女、投机商、囤积居奇者、老瑞士卫队、违背教士公民宪法的神父、撰文为君主制辩护的记者。所有这些人，他们认为实际上都拿着玛丽·安托瓦内特和她在维也纳的朋友们精心策划的阴谋诡计的奥地利委员会的薪水。我的意思是，情况差不多就是这样，不是吗，汤姆？关于玛丽·安托瓦内特和她在维也纳的朋友们的问题，我的意思是，他们并没有错，因为玛丽·安托瓦内特一直在与奥地利人勾结。所以就是这样。我的意思是，这一点很重要。
They mean corrupt former advisors to the King, ladies in waiting at the court who they say are all lesbians, speculators, hoarders, criminals, the old Swiss guards, priests who have defied the civil constitution of the clergy, journalists who have written in defense of the monarchy. All these people they think are in the pay effectively of the sinister Austrian committee that is masterminded by Marie Antoinette and her friends in Vienna. I mean, that's pretty much the case, isn't it, Tom? And on the issue of Marie Antoinette and her friends in Vienna, I mean, they're not wrong because Marie Antoinette has been conniving with the Austrians. So that's the thing. I mean, it's important to say that.
因此，到 8 月 28 日，两天后，丹东现在下令在全市范围内进行突袭搜查，搜查人们的房子。他们在搜寻枪支、搜寻敌方特工、被盗文件、信件。所以，如果你看过任何关于法国大革命的纪录片或电影，你会看到这种非常刻板的形象：一群戴着红帽子的无套裤汉手里拿着长矛，敲着人们的门。浓密的胡渣。对。
So by the 28th of August, two days later, Danton has now ordered raids across the city, raids on people's houses. They're searching for guns, they're searching for enemy agents, stolen documents, letters. So if you've ever seen documentaries or films about the French Revolution, you've seen this sort of quite stereotypical image of a group of sans-culottes with their kind of red hats and their pikes banging on people's doors. Thick stubble. Right.
你藏了一个贵族在地窖里什么的。这就是出处所在。许多历史学家此时引用了一位名叫罗莎莉·朱利安的日记作者的话。其实她是这一时期的一位出色的日记作者，因为她嫁给了一位雅各宾派议员。现在她是一个真正让你的法国大革命观念变得复杂的人。她是一个非常讨人喜欢的人。她博览群书。她受过良好教育。她是卢梭的超级粉丝，是一个巨大号的慈善家和改革者。但她总是在日记里写道，这个城市充满了叛徒，我们必须把他们根除。还有更多的叛徒，还有更多的叛国行为。我认为这些话对于理解接下来要发生的事情非常重要，因为她和许多其他人
You've got an aristot hidden in the cellar or something. That's where this is coming from. Lots of historians at this point cite a diarist called Rosalie Julien. She's a brilliant diarist actually on this period because she is married to a Jacobin deputy. Now she is somebody who really complicates your sense of the French revolution. She's a very likable character. She's very well read. She's very educated. She's a big fan of Rousseau, a massive do-gooder and a reformer. But she is always writing in her diary, the city is full of traitors and we have to root them out. Still more traitors, still more treason. And I think those words are really important to understand what's going to happen because she and so many other
都在说，他们都在监狱里。所有这些监狱都塞满了叛徒。一旦我们的部队，你知道的，这些志愿者出发去面对普鲁士人，叛徒们就会抓住时机。他们会越狱并大肆屠杀巴黎的妇孺。大约半年前，我们做过阿金库尔战役，亨利五世面对法国军队，但他抓了很多俘虏。当他认为自己遭到后方袭击时，我们做过阿金库尔战役，亨利五世面对法国军队，但他抓了很多俘虏，当他认为自己遭到后方袭击时，他下令杀死俘虏，因为显然内部的敌人是非常危险的。这有一点，我的意思是，把法国大革命与阿金库尔战役进行比较，可能从来没有人这样做过，但其中有一点点那样的成分。我认为完全是的，汤姆。
people are saying, they're all in the prisons. All of these prisons are stuffed with traitors. And as soon as our troops, you know, these volunteers march out to face the Prussians, the traitors will seize their moment. They will break out and massacre the women and children of Paris. About half a year ago, we did the Battle of Agincourt and Henry V is facing the French army, but he's taken lots of prisoners. And when he thinks that he's being attacked from the rear, we did the Battle of Agincourt and Henry V is facing the French army, but he's taken lots of prisoners and when he thinks that he's being attacked from the rear, he orders the prisoners killed because obviously the enemy within is highly dangerous. And there's a slight, I mean, comparing the French Revolution to the Battle of Agincourt, not probably something
是的，我认为有一种背后挨刀的感觉即将来临。并且有所有关于监狱越狱的传言。我认为有一种、有一种背后挨刀的感觉即将来临。而且有所有关于监狱越狱的传言。所以整个八月，实际上一直都有传言。巴黎警方一直在报告谣言，称人们即将闯入监狱，我引用一下，“对里面的人迅速执行正义”。事实上，巴黎警方报告这一点并不奇怪，
anyone's ever done before, but there's a slight element of that to it. I think that totally is Tom. Yeah, I think there's a sense of the stab in the back is coming. And there are all these rumours about breakouts in the prisons. I think there's, there's a sense of the stab in the back is coming. And there were all these rumors about breakouts in the prisons. So all through August, actually, there had been rumors. The Paris police had been reporting rumors that people were about to break into the prisons and I quote, render prompt justice to the people inside them. And in fact, it's not surprising that the Paris police are reporting that
因为一些报纸、激进的小册子、海报等等，对他们认为我们应该做什么表达得非常非常明确。我只举两个例子。其中一份报纸叫《人民演说家》，由弗雷龙编辑，他是我们以前谈到过的卡米尔·德穆兰的朋友。弗雷龙写道，我们应该打的第一场仗是在巴黎城内，而不是城外。聚集在这个不幸城镇内的所有保皇党强盗都将在同一天灭亡。
because some newspapers and radical pamphlets and posters and things are very, very explicit about what they think we should do. And I'll just give you two examples. So one is a newspaper called The Orator of the People and it was edited by a guy called Fréron, who's a friend of Camille Desmoulins, who we've talked about before. Fréron wrote this, the first battle we should fight will be inside the walls of Paris, not outside. All the royal brigands clustering inside this unhappy town will perish in the same day.
监狱里挤满了阴谋家。让世界看看我们是如何审判他们的。我的意思是，这很不祥，但没有这个更不祥。这是一个名叫法布尔·代格兰蒂恩的人说的，他是丹东的朋友，一位伟大的朋友，也是一位诗人。当你读他的话时，你会觉得他并不是诗歌界的一个伟大装饰。让我们清除暴政这些卑鄙奴隶的行列。让叛徒的鲜血成为对自由的第一场大屠杀。
The prisons are full of conspirators. Let the world see how we judge them. I mean, that's ominous, but not as ominous as this. This is from a guy called Fabre de Glantine, who was a friend, a great friend of Danton, and who was a poet. He's not a great ornament, I think, to the poetic profession when you read his words. Let us clear the ranks of these vile slaves of tyranny. Let the blood of traitors be the first holocaust to liberty.
我的意思是，他字面上的意思用了“le premier holocaust”这个短语，这样在我们前进以迎接共同的敌人时，我们不会留下任何让我们感到不安的东西。事实上，马拉，所有这些记者中最直言不讳的一个，而且皮肤最差，这并非巧合，我认为马拉说，基本上公民应该去阿贝监狱，把囚犯抓出来，我引述一下，“用剑把他们刺穿”。历史专业中马拉的一些辩护者说，哦，那只是马拉，你知道，他只是说说而已，他并不是真的那个意思，但正如西蒙·沙马所说，
I mean, he literally used the phrase, le premier holocaust, so that in advancing to meet the common enemy, we leave nothing behind to disquiet us. And actually Marat, one of the most outspoken of all these journalists, and has the worst skin, not coincidentally, I think Mara says, like basically citizens should go to the Abbey prison, get the prisoners and I quote, run them through with a sword. And some of Mara's kind of defenders in the historical profession say, oh, that's just Mara, you know, he talks, he doesn't really mean it, but as Simon Sharma says,
你知道的，人们怎么能分辨出区别呢？这就是 8 月 29 日的氛围，普鲁士人到达了凡尔登，凡尔登是法国东部防御线的基石。如果你过了凡尔登，你就进入了马恩河谷。一旦你穿过那里，你就在朝着巴黎前进，而凡尔登在三天后投降了。所以这个坚不可摧的要塞。是的，那个说过他绝不投降的守城指挥官要么自杀了，要么被凡尔登的人民杀死了，凡尔登的人民根本不想经历围城战。
you know, how'd you know how to, how are people supposed to tell the difference? So this is the climate on the 29th of August, the Prussians reach Verdun and Verdun is the keystone of France's Eastern defensive line. If you get past Verdun, you're into the Valley of the Marne. And once you go through that, you are heading towards Paris and Verdun surrenders after three days. So this impregnable fortress. Yeah, the garrison commander who'd said he'd never surrender either kills himself or is killed by the people of Verdun who basically don't fancy a siege at all.
我们就像，好吧，我们放普鲁士人进来。好的。所以凡尔登投降了，消息在 9 月 2 日星期日传到巴黎。普鲁士人突破了防线，现在你有了，我的意思是这是一个非凡的场景。你有敲响的教堂钟声，勒沃辛（Revocene）上有敲响警报的大炮。这就是丹东发表丘吉尔式演讲的时候。完全正确。丹东发表了演讲。全城贴满了海报，武装起来，武装起来。敌人就在大门口。那天下午，我们可以确凿地发生了一些事情，但我们不能
We're like, yeah, we'll let the Prussians in. Fine. So Verdun surrenders and the news arrives in Paris on Sunday the 2nd of September. The Prussians are broken through and now you've got, I mean it's an extraordinary scene. You have kind of church bells ringing, there are cannons on the Revocene sounding the alert. And this is when Danton gives his Churchillian address. Exactly. Danton gives his address. There are posters going up across the city to arms, to arms. The enemy is at the gates. Now that afternoon, we can be pretty sure that something else happened, but we can't
确切地知道是什么，因为文件后来被销毁了。它们在 1870 到 1871 年的事件中被销毁了。这很讽刺，不是吗？普鲁士人又一次巴黎一日游。所以看起来发生的事情是，一些区，也就是巴黎的这些社区委员会，讨论了我们如何消灭监狱里的这些人。有很多人说这是一个令人不快但必要的选择，但基本上总得有人去做。
be exactly certain what, because the documents were later destroyed. They were destroyed in the events of 1870, 71. It's ironic, isn't it? Another Prussian day trip to Paris. So what seems to have happened is that some of the sections, these are the kind of neighbourhood councils in Paris, discussed how we eliminate these people in the prisons. And there are lots of people saying it's an unpleasant necessity, but basically somebody has to do it.
现在，这并不是说区里下达了命令，但基调已经定下了。大约在这个时候，首席监狱长来到市政厅见丹东，他说：“我真的担心监狱里人们的安全。”丹东说：“je me fous bien des prisoniers。”我对囚犯一点也不在乎，基本上让他们自生自灭吧。但平心而论，我的意思是，原因之一是他抽不出人手来守卫路障。人数是有限的。显然，从他的角度来看，主要的威胁
Now, that's not to say the sections ordered it, but the tone has kind of been set. About this point, the chief prison inspector comes to Danton in the Hôtel de Ville in City Hall and he says, I'm genuinely worried about the safety of the people in the prisons. And Danton says, je me fous bien des prisoniers. I don't give a damn about the prisoners, like basically let them fend for themselves. But to be fair to him, I mean, one of the reasons for that is that he can't spare people from the barricades. There's only a finite number of people. And obviously the main threat from his perspective
是普鲁士人的逼近。汤姆，我对此感到非常惊讶。我想我以为你会站在这个方程式的另一边，但现在从你在整集节目中的表现来看，我很清楚，你知道的，你将在这个问题上采取非常多米尼克·桑布拉克对待塔中王子们的立场，是吗？好吧，不，但我确实认为，像丹东这样的人、革命的负责人可能会不关心囚犯和囚犯的安全，这与巴黎的整体局势有关。
is the approach of the Prussian. Tom, I'm so surprised at this. I think I thought you were going to be on the other side of this equation, but it's very clear to me now from the way you've conducted yourself in this whole episode that, you know, you're going to take a very Dominic Sambra at princes in the tower line on this issue, are you? Well, no, but I do think that there are reasons why someone like Dantaux, people in charge of the revolution, might be unconcerned with prisoners and the security of the prisoners that relates to the overall situation in Paris.
是的，挺有道理的。而且别忘了，每个人都认为囚犯是彻头彻尾的坏蛋和叛徒之类的人。当然，但我认为说，“我们没空搭理他们。”是的，这是由军事紧急情况所证明的。很有道理。听众可以自己做决定，不是吗？我不得不说西奥同意你的看法。他在聊天区里写道：说得好，汤姆。那挺好的。让我们进入正题。大约在那天下午两点半左右，9月2日，凡尔登的消息传来了。有一群囚犯正被护送穿过城市，从司法宫到阿贝监狱，他们是王室官员、朝臣和天主教神父。
Yeah, fair enough. And also don't forget, everybody thinks the prisoners are total villains and traitors and all of that stuff. Of course, but I think that saying, you know, we can't bother with them. Yeah, it's justified by military exigencies. Fair enough. Listeners can make up their own minds, can't they? I have to say Theo agrees with you. He's written in the chat. Well said, Tom. So that's nice. So let's get into the story. Sometime about 2.30 that afternoon, the 2nd of September, the news has come in from Verdun. There was a group of prisoners being escorted through the city from the Palais de Justice to the Abbey prison and they are royal officials, they're courtiers and they're Catholic priests.
由于战争带来的恐慌，街上显然挤满了人，当他们乘着这些马车经过时，许多人对他们大声辱骂。当他们到达位于圣日耳曼德普雷的阿贝监狱时，这是一座前修道院，因此得名，一群人拦住了他们。这些人是国民卫队员、无套裤汉，各种角色混杂在一起。他们拦住马车，把囚犯拖出来，拖进附近的一个区总部，也就是一座修道院里。那里聚集了很多人，人们在大喊大叫，这些人是人民的敌人。你知道，为什么要带他们去监狱？为什么现在不直接除掉他们？其中两三个囚犯试图逃跑，试图逃脱或为他们的生命而战
The streets are obviously packed with people because of the war panic and a lot of people shout abuse at them as they pass in these kind of carriages. As they get towards the Abbey prison, which is in Saint-Germain-des-Prés, it's a former Abbey, hence the name, a group of people stop them. These people are National Guardsmen, Sonculotte, a mixture of characters. They stop the carriages, they drag the prisoners out and they drag them into the nearby section headquarters, which is a convent. And there's a great crowd of people there and the people are shouting, these are enemies of the people. You know, why take them to the prison? Why not just get rid of them now? Two or three of those prisoners try to break out, try to get away or fight
等等，发生了一场争执，他们被殴打并被用刀砍死，他们的尸体被留在庭院里。其余的囚犯，大约 20 人左右，只是站在那里，完全惊呆了，不知道会发生什么。一个即席法庭成立了，并宣布他们有罪。然后，以一种非常系统的方式，他们一个接一个地顺着台阶走进花园，那里聚集了一群拿着刀、斧头的人。有一个人显然是个木匠，因为他买了他的锯子，一个接一个，
for their lives or whatever, there's a scuffle, they're beaten up and they are hacked to death with knives and their bodies are left in the courtyard. The rest of the prisoners are just, you know, 20 people or so are just standing there absolutely traumatized and shocked, wondering what's going to happen. An impromptu tribunal is set up and it declares them guilty. Then one by one, in a very methodical way, they're led down the steps into the garden and there a group of men has assembled with knives, axes, hatchets. There's a guy who's clearly a carpenter because he's bought his saw and one by one,
他们被砍死。从一开始就要说清楚，这是第一起事件。这不是一阵疯狂的狂热。这不是一场暴力狂欢。它很安静。它是经过深思熟虑的，这群人慢条斯理。杀死所有人大约花了半个小时，然后就结束了。而在楼上，那些还在那里的人——房间里绝对挤满了人，他们正在辩论，既然我们已经杀了这些人，为什么我们不直接走进阿贝监狱，对里面的人也这么做呢。
they are hacked to death. It's important to say right from the beginning, this is the first incident. It is not a mad frenzy. It's not an orgy of violence. It is quiet. It's considered the guys take their time. It takes about half an hour to kill all these men and then it is done. And upstairs, the people who are still there there the room is absolutely full of people and they are debating now that we've killed these people why don't we just go into the abbey prison and do the same with everybody who is in there.
但同样不一定是要杀死他们，而是要对他们进行审判，正如我们将看到的，并非所有人都被杀死，你完全正确。对他们进行审判。正如我们将看到的，并非所有人都被杀死，你完全正确。正当那群人在争论他们将如何做时，另一拨人闯入了大约一英里外的另一座监狱，叫卡姆监狱，它曾经是一座加尔默罗修会的女修道院。所以很多这样的监狱都是由修道院和宗教场所改造的。在这座监狱里，大约有 160 名神父。人群再次聚集，组织了一个临时的法庭。他们逐一叫出囚犯的名字。他们把他们带到花园里。其中一些人被枪杀。
But again not necessarily to kill them to sit in judgment on them as we'll see not everybody is killed you're absolutely right. to sit in judgment on them. As we'll see, not everybody is killed, you're absolutely right. While that crowd is all debating and arguing about how they're going to do it, a separate group breaks into another prison about a mile away called the Karm, it's a former Karmalite convent. So a lot of these prisons are convents and abbeys and religious houses that have been converted. In this prison, there are about 160 priests. crowd again, organizes a kind of improvised tribunal. They call out the prisoners names one by one. They take them out into the garden. Some of them are shot.
大部分人再次被砍死。其中一些人试图爬过墙壁，甚至爬上树逃跑，但他们被拖了回来，用刀结果了。再说一次，四分之一的人被饶恕了。等等，160人中有115人在这次事件中被杀。绝对是这样，因为人们很容易认为这是一场大屠杀。否则你不会拿自己的生命开玩笑。当然不会。这真的支持了你刚才所说的，这不是那种气急败坏、疯狂暴徒的狂热。它经过了更多的深思熟虑，因此我认为实际上比那更加可怕。同意。顺便说一句，我们俩得到的数字不同。这并不是因为我们其中一个人是对的，另一个人是错的。这是因为每本历史书给出的数字都不一样。所以是的，关于这些数字有很多混乱。
Most of them they're hacked to death again. Some of them try to climb over the walls or they even climb trees to get away, but they are dragged back and finished off with knives. Again, just to say, I mean, a quarter of them are spared. Well, hold on, 115 people out of 160 are killed in this. Absolutely, because I think it's easy to think that it is a total massacre. Or you wouldn't take your chances with that. Of course not. It's just really supporting what you were saying, that this isn't a kind of frothing
与此同时，行刑队已经在阿贝监狱以及其他一些监狱开始了行动。在所有这些监狱里，都是同样的套路。实际上，我认为用“行刑队”比“暴徒”更合适。他们经常被描述为暴徒，但这些是有组织的小分队。他们几乎总是举行这种法庭。一旦罪名成立，他们就把人带到庭院里，然后用刀刺死或砍死他们。
at the mouth, mad mob frenzy. It's much more considered and therefore I think actually much more frightening than that. Agreed. And by the way, we both get different figures. That's not because one of us is right and the other is wrong. It's because every history book gives different figures on this. So yeah, there is a lot of confusion about the figures.
我们只知道其中一个组织者的名字，一个名叫斯坦尼斯拉斯·马拉尔的人，他是一名职员。他曾去过巴士底狱。他在妇女进军凡尔赛事件中是个大人物。他似乎是那种在革命和混乱时期被抛出来的人。所以有点像个恶霸。
Now meanwhile, the Death Squad has got started in the Abbey prison and also in some of the other prisons. And in all of them, it is the same kind of routine. I think actually Death Squad is better than mob. They're often described as mobs, but these are kind of organized teams of men. They almost always hold this kind of tribunal. They bring people out into the courtyard once they've been found guilty and then they stab them or hack them to death.
你可以说他是那种会成为准军事领导人的人。他喜欢这一切，而且显然这是他的时刻。但有趣的是，不是吗？实际上知道名字的人这么少，很大程度上是因为在适当的时候，成为一名“九月屠杀者”（septembriseur，就像他们后来被称为的那样）是非常危险的，因为它后来被视为革命声誉上的一个巨大污点。不过并不是立即如此，我认为这反映了这样一个事实：这确实不是由大人物、丹东或罗伯斯庇尔等人组织起来的。它可能来自各个区。而组织它的人也不是那些以后会成为伟大
And we only know one of the names of the people who organized this, a guy called Stanislaus Maillard, who was a clerk. He'd been at the Bastille. He'd been a big figure in the Women's March on Versailles. And he seems to have been one of those people who's thrown up by these periods of revolution and kind of chaos. So a bit of a bully.
人物、家喻户晓的名字的人。汤姆，我认为你完全说对了。我认为这是被组织的。并且就组织感而言，它处于非常非常低的水平。就是这些社区委员会。公社，我们知道他们讨论过，那是一个接管巴黎的起义委员会。我们知道他们讨论过，他们说，正如你所说，没有足够的人来保护监狱。我们需要他们在路障上。公社的一个委员会发表了一份声明，由马拉签署，囚犯是会屠杀我们的孩子和妇女的强盗。
You could say he's the kind of person who would be a paramilitary leader. And he loves all this. And and obviously this is his moment. But it's interesting, isn't it, that actually so few names are known, and in large part that is because in due course to be a septembriseur, as they come to be called, is highly dangerous because it comes to be seen as a terrible blot on the reputation of the revolution. Not immediately though, and I think that that reflects the fact that this is genuinely not being organized by the big names, by Danton or Robespierre or whatever. It's coming probably from the sections. And the people who are organizing it are not people who will go on to great
这些正义行动对于通过使用恐怖来威慑这些叛徒军团是必不可少的。但这并不是说马拉被点名说他是领导者。不，不，他没有亲自进去。他激发了它。但我认为这些基本上是袭击了杜伊勒里宫的人？是的，我认为是这样。这是来自巴黎工人阶级地区的人。他们是巴黎劳动人口的代表性人物。
things to become kind of famous names. I think you're absolutely right, Tom. I think the is being organized. And in so far as there is a sense of organization, it's at a very, very sort of low level. It's these kind of neighborhood councils. The commune, we know that they talked about that's an instructional council that's taking control of Paris. We know they talked about it and they said, your point, there weren't enough men to protect the prisons. We need them on the barricades. One of the commune's committees issued a statement signed by Marat, the prisoners are brigands who will slaughter our children and our women.
是的，我想是这样。我的意思是，我们将在下半场讨论巴黎人口对此的看法，但我认为你完全正确，基本上他们相当能够代表这个城市和街道，我猜。这是街头的复仇。对九月大屠杀抱有更多同情心的历史学家是这么说的。我的意思是，大人物们，大人物们知道这件事正在发生，但他们什么也没做。
These acts of justice are indispensable to deter through the use of terror these legions of traitors. But it's not like Marat is being named as a guy who's leading it. No, no, he's not going in. He's inspired it. But I think these are basically the people who had attacked the Tuileries, right? Yeah, I think that's right. It's people from the working class areas of Paris. They are representative figures from the working population of Paris.
丹东对吉伦特派领袖布里索说，这些死是安抚巴黎人民不可或缺的牺牲。内政部长让-马里·罗兰，罗兰夫人的丈夫，吉伦特派社交圈的伟大核心人物，他说，人民在复仇中表现出可怕的一面，正在行使某种正义。他们在为之找借口，而且某种程度上，我的意思是他们什么也没做。将恐怖与某种正义联系起来，我认为这正是正在发生的事情。
Yeah, I think so. I mean, and we'll talk about in the second half about what the population of Paris think of it, but I think you're absolutely right that basically they are pretty representative of the city and of the streets, I guess. It is the vengeance of the streets. That's what historians who are more sympathetic to the September mass say. I mean, on the big wigs, the big wigs know this is happening, but they don't do anything about it.
是的，我认为这非常具有法国大革命的色彩，不是吗？这就是第一天，但当然，这只是最初的好几天。第二天，到了星期一，第三天，阿贝监狱的人——第一个被针对的监狱——在那里工作了大约 24 小时。与此同时，其他人已经转移到其他监狱。有一座名为圣菲曼的神学院，关押着神父。有一座名为圣伯纳德的女修道院。有一座名为圣菲曼的神学院，关押着神父。有一座名为圣伯纳德的女修道院。比塞特尔有一座关押轻罪犯的精神病院。也许最令人震惊的是萨尔佩特里埃妇女收容所，那里关押着妓女，人们一直在开玩笑说，不是吗，我们应该送
Danton says to Briceau, Girondin leader, the deaths are an indispensable sacrifice to appease the people of Paris. The interior minister, Jean-Marie Roulon, the husband of Madame Roulon, the great sort of lynchpin of the Girondins social circle, he says the people terrible in its vengeance is exercising a kind of justice. They're making excuses for it and kind of, I mean they do nothing about it. That association of terror with a kind of justice, I think is exactly what's happening.
丹东对吉伦特派领袖布里索说，这些死亡是安抚巴黎人民不可或缺的牺牲。内政部长让-马里·罗兰，罗兰夫人的丈夫，吉伦特派社交圈的核心人物，他说人民可怕的复仇正在行使一种正义。他们在为之开脱，而且可以说，他们对此坐视不管。这种将恐怖与某种正义联系在一起的做法，我认为正是当时正在发生的事情。
Yeah, I think that was very French Revolution, isn't it? So that's the first day, but of course, it's just the first several days. The next day, you get to Monday the third, the men at the Abbey prison, the first prison to be targeted, they're there for about 24 hours working away. And meanwhile, other men have moved on to other prisons. There's a seminary called Saint-Famain, which holds priests. There's a convent called Saint-Bernard. There's a seminary called Saint-Famain which holds priests. There's a convent called Saint Bernard. There's an asylum at Bissetre which holds petty criminals. Perhaps most shockingly the Sault Petrière women's hospice which holds prostitutes and people have been joking hadn't they, we should send
是的，我认为这非常具有法国大革命的色彩，不是吗？所以那是第一天，但当然，这只是最初的几天。第二天，到了星期一，即9月3日，在作为首要袭击目标的阿拜监狱里，那些人已经在那里忙碌了大约24个小时。与此同时，其他人已经转移到了别的监狱。有一个关押神甫的圣菲尔曼神学院。有一个叫圣伯纳德的修道院。（重复省略）还有一个关押轻罪犯人的比塞特疯人院。也许最令人震惊的是关押着妓女的萨尔佩特里埃妇女收容所，人们之前还在开玩笑说，对吧，我们应该把...
Marianne Trenet to the Sault Petrière. So there we're not talking about priests or courtiers or you know royalist journalists. These people are actually poor, petty criminals, prostitutes and so on and this is I think where it gets particularly shocking. So be set, they killed probably a hundred and fifty hundred and sixty people. A lot of them are very young, about forty of them are probably under 18. One of them is 12, two of them are 13, three of them are 14 and so on. The Sambarna, the people who are killed there, perhaps 70 of them, they're forgers. And the Sonkhalot hate forgers because of the paper money. They think the paper money is all a plot. They think that the forgers
玛丽安·特雷内送到了萨尔佩特里埃。所以我们在那里谈论的不是牧师、朝臣，或者你知道的保王党记者。这些人其实是穷人、小偷小摸的罪犯、妓女等等，我认为这正是事情变得格外令人震惊的地方。所以说，他们杀了一百五到一百六十人左右。其中很多人非常年轻，大约四十人可能不到18岁。其中一人12岁，两人13岁，三人14岁，以此类推。萨姆巴纳，在那里被杀死的人，大约70人，他们是伪造犯。索恩卡洛特人痛恨伪造犯，因为纸币。他们认为纸币全是一个阴谋。他们认为伪造犯
have been working with counter-revolutionaries to undermine it and to drive up grain prices. So if you're a forger, you've got to go. So David Andress, who's written a wonderful book on the terror, he comments on this iconically, September 1792 was not a good time to be a captured forger. And that is putting it mildly. And not a good time to be a prostitute. So, Sault Petriere, probably 40 prostitutes. Or indeed a criminal, generally, right? Because you were talking about how throughout the revolutionary period, people have been assuming that criminals are in association with
一直与反革命分子勾结来破坏它，并推高粮价。所以如果你是个伪造者，你就得完蛋。因此，大卫·安德烈斯，他写了一本关于恐怖统治的精彩书籍，对此作出了具有代表性的评论：1792年9月可不是当一个被捕伪造者的好时候。这还算是轻描淡写的说法。而且当一个妓女也不是什么好时候。所以，在萨尔佩特里埃，大概有40名妓女。或者实际上，泛指任何罪犯，对吧？因为你刚才谈到，在整个革命期间，人们一直认为罪犯与
counter-revolutionary forces. And this basically seems to be why people are targeting people who are in for criminality rather than for political crimes. Yeah. I think actually, Tom, since 1789, maybe I don't know enough about pre-revolutionary Paris, but I think certainly since 1789, you know, we talked about the grand peur, the great fear of the countryside.
反革命势力有关联。这基本上似乎就是为什么人们把矛头指向那些因犯罪而入狱的人，而不是因政治犯罪而入狱的人的原因。是的。我想实际上，汤姆，自1789年以来，也许我对革命前的巴黎了解不够，但我认为肯定自1789年以来，你知道的，我们谈到了大恐慌，也就是乡村的大恐慌。
And that's a huge fear of brigands, isn't it? Who are going to ride over the horizon and trample your crops and burn because they're working with the local aristocrats. Well, I think in Paris, there has been the same thing with criminals, you know, anxiety about street crime and a belief that crime in some obscure way is connected with the court. Well again, David Andress, he makes the comment in his book on the terror, that there were always 30,000 of them for some reason. That again and again is his figure.
人们对强盗有着极大的恐惧，不是吗？他们会骑马越过地平线，践踏你的庄稼，四处放火，因为他们与当地的贵族勾结。好吧，我认为在巴黎，对罪犯也是一样的情况，你知道的，对街头犯罪的焦虑，以及一种认为某种隐秘的犯罪与宫廷有关的信念。好吧，同样是大卫·安德烈斯，他在那本关于恐怖统治的书里评论说，由于某种原因，那种人总是多达3万。这在他的著作中一次又一次出现。
There are 30,000 brigands, there are 30,000 criminals, they're all plotting. And clearly it's just part of the temper of the time. It's what people are obsessing about and terrified of. Yeah, absolutely. Now actually you made a really good point earlier on. You were keen to emphasize that not everybody is killed. The single most famous kind of insider account, the one that was best known in 1790s France, came from somebody who did survive.
有3万名强盗，有3万名罪犯，他们都在密谋。显然，这只是当时风气的一部分。这是人们痴迷和恐惧的对象。是的，绝对如此。其实你刚才提出了一个非常好的观点。你急于强调并不是所有人都被杀了。最著名的一种内部叙述，也就是1790年代的法国最广为人知的叙述，来自一个幸存下来的人。
He was an army officer and a royalist journalist called François Jean-Niac Samaillard. And he was in the Abbey of Saint-Germain, a prisoner, and he wrote a book afterwards with a brilliant title, My Agony of 38 Hours. I'd buy that. And he says in that basically he was in the prison and he was in his cell and his cell had a little window and he couldn't see into the courtyard but he could hear. And he said basically that was the execution ground and for hours he was just sitting there in his cell listening to people being murdered. And he said the killers worked in silence
他是一名陆军军官，也是一名保王党记者，名叫弗朗索瓦·让-尼亚克·萨迈拉尔。他是圣日耳曼修道院的囚犯，后来他写了一本书，书名非常惊艳：《我38小时的痛苦》。我会买这本书。他在书中基本上说，他当时在监狱里，待在自己的牢房里，牢房有一个小窗户，他看不到庭院，但他能听见。他说，基本上那是行刑地，他只是坐在牢房里听了好几个小时的人被谋杀。他说，行刑者是在沉默中动手的
and that made him even more terrifying. He could hear people being let out and then the kind of grunting and the hacking of the blows and all that kind of thing. And he said all that he would hear, the only speech was the basically after everybody was killed, the killers would shout, Vive la Nation, long live the nation, and then they would move on to the next. Now a guard, he'd made friends with the guard and the guard said to him, I'll let you watch some of the interrogations before the tribunal so you can work out the right answers. So eventually, 4th of September, at one o'clock in the morning, it's his turn. Imagine that.
这让他感到更加恐怖。他能听到人们被放出来，然后是那种哼哧声、砍杀的闷响以及诸如此类的声音。他说他所能听到的，唯一的说话声基本上是每个人被杀后，行刑者会高喊：“法兰西民族万岁！民族万岁！”，然后他们就会转移到下一个目标。现在有个看守，他和这个看守交了朋友，看守对他说：“我让你在法庭审讯前旁听几次，这样你就能琢磨出正确的答案。”最终，9月4日凌晨一点，轮到他了。想象一下。
I mean, that's terrifying. Somebody shouts out your name and you're led down the corridor and then you go into this room which is packed with people, a lot of stubble, a lot of sweat and a group of men at the end. You have to answer these questions. And he said the men who took him in had blood all over their shirts. So he goes in and if his account is remotely true, and of course, it may be exaggerated, he did really well.
我的意思是，太可怕了。有人大喊你的名字，你被带过走廊，然后走进这个挤满了人的房间，里面有很多胡茬、很多汗水，尽头是一群男人。你必须回答这些问题。他说带他进去的那些人衬衫上全都是血。于是他进去了，如果他的叙述有那么一点真实性，当然，它可能被夸大了，他应对得非常出色。
He was very calm. He said, listen, I used to be a Royalist, but I'm not anymore. Circumstances have changed. And of course I've changed my mind as we all have. I've never plotted and conspired with anybody. I've never been interested in politics. You know, I was just a journalist and you know, it's bad luck that I'm here."
他非常冷静。他说：“听着，我以前是个保王党，但我现在不是了。情况变了。当然，我的想法也变了，就像我们所有人一样。我从未与任何人密谋策划。我从来对政治不感兴趣。你知道的，我只是个记者，你知道的，我在这里纯属运气不好。”
And they acquitted him and they sent him home with an escort of sonculot. And when he got back to his boarding house, his landlord who saw him coming with these men covered in blood, got out his pocketbook to give these men money to basically pay them off and the men said, oh, we don't do this for money. Because they see themselves as agents of justice and I mean just to emphasize this that actually of the prisons in which the killings are taking place over half of those who are detained in the prisons do survive this experience which isn't in any way to underplay you know I mean almost half the population of a prison being
他们宣告他无罪，并派了一队索恩库洛特护送他回家。当他回到公寓时，他的房东看到他带着这些浑身是血的人走来，便拿出记事本要给这些人钱来打发他们，而那些人说：“哦，我们不为钱做这个。”因为他们把自己当作正义的化头，我的意思是，仅仅强调这一点——实际上，在发生杀戮的监狱中，被关押在监狱中的人有一半以上在这场经历中幸存了下来，这绝不是在淡化——我的意思是，几乎一半的监狱人口被
slaughtered is hideous but it's a glass half empty glass half full perspective, I suppose. So it depends. I mean, so interesting. It depends which book you read. I can tell you've been reading David Andrews book because he's very much of the glass half full, isn't he? He's like, well, look at all the prisoners who survived. Nobody talks about them.
屠杀是极其可怕的，但我想，这是一个“杯子半空”还是“杯子半满”的视角。所以这得看情况。我的意思是，太有趣了。这取决于你读的是哪本书。我看得出你在读大卫·安德鲁斯的书，因为他非常倾向于“杯子半满”的观点，不是吗？他就像是在说，好吧，看看所有幸存下来的囚犯。没有人谈论他们。
Anyway, so this guy gave the right answers. But of course, there are some people who cannot bring themselves to give the right answers. And after the break, well, that's come to the most celebrated of all of those and that's somebody you've talked about before Tom and I know you have a bit of a torn dress for this unfortunate lady. It's Marie Antoinette's friend, the Princess de Lamballe. So we'll be coming to her story after the break and be warned things are going to get ugly.
无论如何，这个家伙给出了正确的答案。但是当然，有些人无论如何也无法让自己给出正确的答案。中场休息之后，好吧，我们将谈到其中最著名的一个人，也就是你以前谈过的人，汤姆，我知道你对这位不幸的女士有点心软。她就是玛丽·安托瓦内特的密友，朗巴勒亲王妃。所以中场休息后我们将讲述她的故事，请注意，事情要变得惨烈了。
And that is a very serious warning. She received a saber blow behind her head which took off her cap. Her long hair fell onto her shoulders. Another saber blow hit her eye. Blood gushed out, her dress was stained with it. She tried to fall down to let herself die, but they forced her to get up again to walk over corpses and the crowd, silent, watched the slaughter. So that is one of numerous accounts and we'll be looking at the range of what is reported about this death describing probably the best known of all the victims of the September massacres who is the Princess de l'H Lombard, who as you mentioned just before the break, Dominic, we've talked about before in our
这是一个非常严厉的警告。她的脑后挨了一记军刀，帽子被削掉了。她长长的金发垂在肩膀上。另一记军刀击中了她的眼睛。鲜血喷涌而出，她的裙子被染红了。她试图倒下让自己死去，但他们强迫她重新站起来，跨过尸体，而人群则默默地注视着这场屠杀。这就是众多记述中的一个，我们将探讨关于这一死因的各种报道，这些报道描述了九月大屠杀中最广为人知的受害者，也就是朗巴勒亲王妃。正如你在中场休息前刚刚提到的，多米尼克，我们在
very first episode. Episode one is season one in our episode on Marie Antoinette, that she was a very close friend of Marie Antoinette. She's of impeccable background, a princess of the House of Savoy. She was notorious for being a bit dumb, was said to have a tendency to repeat clever things that she'd heard people say and then pretend that she'd made it up herself. But against that, there are other people who rated her intelligence quite highly. She was a friend of Benjamin Franklin. So again, a bit like Marie Antoinette. I mean, she's not entirely opposed to the kind of traditions of sentiment and fondness for the poor that are feeding into the revolution.
第一季的第一集里讨论过玛丽·安托瓦内特，她与玛丽·安托瓦内特是非常要好的朋友。她出身无可挑剔，是萨伏伊王室的公主。她以有点愚笨而闻名，据说有一种习惯，喜欢重复自己听别人说过的聪明话，然后假装那是她自己想出来的。但与此相对的是，也有其他人对她的智商评价很高。她是本杰明·富兰克林的友人。所以同样地，有点像玛丽·安托瓦内特。我的意思是，她并不完全反对那种正在滋养革命的情感传统和对穷人的喜爱。
But she becomes, like Marie Antoinette herself, a symbol of everything that is most rotten and putrid of the Ancien Régime. She is seen as kind of a vampire like Marie Antoinette. She's assumed to be having a lesbian affair with her. And this reflects the fact that the Princess de Lombard unlike Madame de Polignac, another of Marie internet's great friends who had fled the process. The Lombard had stayed with Marie Antoinette and had served her as her mistress of ceremonies in the Tuileries. And it is this loyalty to her, which will doom her.
但她和玛丽·安托瓦内特本人一样，成为了旧制度中最腐朽、最恶臭的一切的象征。她被视为像玛丽·安托瓦内特一样的吸血鬼。人们认为她与玛丽有同性恋爱关系。这反映了一个事实：朗巴勒亲王妃不同于波利尼亚克夫人——玛丽·安托瓦内特的另一位伟大朋友，后者已经逃离了审判。朗巴勒留在了玛丽·安托瓦内特身边，并在杜伊勒里宫担任她的宫廷女官长。正是对玛丽的这种忠诚，注定了她的毁灭。
Yeah, that's right, Tom. So just to give people a sense of what's coming. We had a big debate, didn't we? About what reading we would come in with this half. That is actually one of the less bloodthirsty, one of the least horrible of all the potential readings that we could have chosen because nothing good is going to happen to her. She's 42 years old at this point. I'd always imagined her as being quite young, but of course, Marie Antoinette herself is
是的，没错，汤姆。所以为了让大家对即将发生的事情有一个概念。我们进行了一场激烈的辩论，不是吗？关于我们在这一半节目中要引入什么材料。这实际上是所有我们本可以挑选的潜在读物中，不那么嗜血、最不恐怖的一种，因为没有任何好事会降临到她头上。她当时42岁。我一直以为她很年轻，但当然，玛丽·安托瓦内特本人在
not terribly young at this point. She's been with Marie Antoinette all this time. She'd had a pretty terrible life with the Princess de Lamballe, married at 16, widowed at 19. Her husband probably gave her syphilis so she couldn't have children. And her father-in-law had banned her from remarrying. So she's sort of stuck hanging around Mère Antoinette. And as you say, she is extremely loyal.
这个时候也不是非常年轻了。她一直和玛丽·安托瓦内特在一起。朗巴勒亲王妃过着相当悲惨的生活，16岁结婚，19岁守寡。她的丈夫可能传染给她梅毒，导致她无法生育。她的公公禁止她再婚。所以她有点被困在玛丽·安托瓦内特身边。正如你所说，她极为忠诚。
She's perceived as very haughty, isn't she? I think that's because she's shy. Yeah. She's a nervous person, sickly. Socially maladroit. Yeah, absolutely. But as you've said, and as you brilliantly described in those episodes about Marie Antoinette at the very beginning of the whole French Revolution cycle, she has always played a
人们觉得她非常傲慢，不是吗？我想那是害羞造成的。是的。她是一个神经质、体弱多病的人。社交笨拙。是的，绝对如此。但正如你所说，正如你在整个法国大革命周期的最初几集里对玛丽·安托瓦内特的精彩描述那样，她一直在
very prominent part in the kind of pornographic demonology of the court. Yeah, absolutely. And I think this is so important for understanding the things that will come to be written about her death is that Paris has been saturated in appalling pornographic fantasies about Marie Antoinette and about her female attendants and friends. And this provides a kind of terrible context for what will happen to her and what will be reported about her fate. Yeah, so on the 3rd of September which is the second day of the massacres the killers came to prison called La Force where she has been taken with the other ladies-in-waiting and with the Royal Children's former governess Madame de
宫廷的色情恶魔学中扮演着非常突出的角色。是的，绝对如此。我认为这对于理解后来写关于她之死的内容至关重要，那就是巴黎充斥着关于玛丽·安托瓦内特以及她的女侍从和朋友的骇人色情幻想。这为将要发生在她的身上以及关于她命运的报道提供了一种可怕的背景。是的，所以在9月3日——大屠杀的第二天，行刑者来到了一座名为拉福斯的监狱，她和其他女侍从以及王室儿童的前家庭教师图尔西耶夫人一起被带到了那里，那里设立了一个法庭，有七个人。其中最著名的是一个名叫雅克·埃贝尔的激进记者。他基本上让马拉看起来像是《卫报》的专栏作家。他非常极端。他有点特朗普式的风格，不是吗？他给对手起绰号。
Toursille and there's a tribunal set up there, seven people. The most famous of them is a radical journalist called Jacques Hebert. He basically makes Marat look like a columnist for the Guardian. He's kind of very extreme. He's a bit Trump-esque, isn't he? He has nicknames for his opponents. Yes, incredibly aggressive. So this tribunal has been working its way through the prisoners of the force.
是的，极其具有攻击性。所以这个法庭一直在拉福斯监狱的囚犯中挨个审讯。
They have very strange sort of code. If they say at the end of your hearing, Vive la Nation, then you are spared. You're free to go. If they say you're free to go, you are killed. So it's slightly confusing. Anyway, the process to Lambelle is brought out and it's all actually very quick. They say, did you know anything about the plot to kill the people by the Swiss guards at the Tuileries?
他们有一套非常奇怪的暗号。如果在你听审结束时他们说“民族万岁”，那么你就被饶恕了。你就可以自由离开了。如果他们说你可以自由离开了，你就会被杀死。所以这有点令人困惑。无论如何，朗巴勒亲王妃被带了出来，实际上这一切非常快。他们问：“你知道关于杜伊勒里宫的瑞士卫队刺杀人们的阴谋吗？”
So again, harking back to the sense people by the Swiss guards at the Tuileries? So again, harking back to the sense that it's the guards who are at fault and it's a royal conspiracy against the people. And she says, no, I knew nothing about this. Will you swear to liberty and equality and hatred of the king and queen? She says, yes, I'll happily swear to liberty and equality, but I cannot swear hatred to the king and queen. It's not in my heart.
所以再次回到了那种感觉：是卫队有过错，这是一场针对人民的王室阴谋。而她说：“不，我对一无所知。”“你肯宣誓效忠自由与平等，并对国王和王后怀恨在心吗？”她说：“是的，我乐意宣誓效忠自由与平等，但我不能宣誓痛恨国王和王后。这不是我内心所想。”
Now, at that point, by some accounts, there was a friend or an agent of her father-in-law or something like this who was in the room who whispered to her, just said, say you swear it and they'll let you go. And she said, I have nothing more to say. It's indifferent to me if I die earlier or later, I've made the sacrifice of my life. And the tribunal says, very well, let Madam be set at liberty, which means you're for the chop. And then she is led outside into the courtyard.
在那一刻，根据某些记述，房间里有她公公的一位朋友或代理人之类的人，对她耳语说：“你就说你宣誓，他们就会放了你。”而她却说：“我没什么好说的。早死晚死对我来说都一样，我已经为生命做出了牺牲。”法庭说：“很好，让夫人重获自由”，这意味着你要被砍头了。然后她被带到外面的庭院里。
And now what happens next is the subject of innumerable, undoubtedly sensationalized, exaggerated, and probably entirely fictional accounts. Many of them exaggerated, and many of them frankly, probably fictional. What do we actually know? What we know is that the same day the third, a group of sans-culottes, delivered her body, sans head, to one of the sections. Later the head was retrieved and these were buried privately by servants of her family. That's what we actually know.
接下来发生的事情，成为了无数无疑被感官化、夸大且可能完全是虚构的记述的主题。许多被夸大了，许多坦率地说可能是虚构的。我们实际上知道什么？我们知道的是，在同一天，即3号，一具没有头颅的尸体被一群索恩古洛特人送到了其中一个区。后来，头部被找回，并由她家族的仆人秘密安葬。这就是我们实际知道的。
So we know that her head was cut off and was not there to be taken with the rest of her body to the section notary. Correct. So there are a couple of issues and how she was killed, which is the subject of an enormous sort of very prurient frankly pornographic speculation in the 1790s and afterwards. And then there was what happens to her head afterwards, which becomes a very, very famous part of the French Revolutionary story. So the detail that you just mentioned about what happens to her head, which I think does
所以我们知道她的头被砍掉了，并没有和身体的其他部分一起被带到区公所。没错。所以这里有几个问题：一是她是如何被杀的，这是1790年代及以后引发大量、极其猥亵、坦率地说是色情猜想的主题；二是她死后头部的去向，这成为了法国大革命故事中非常、非常著名的一部分。关于你刚刚提到的关于她头部的去向的细节，我认为确实
happen, the story is, is that it gets put on a pike and it gets taken to the prison, the temple fortress where the royal family are being kept and of course Marie Antoinette, the friend and in the opinion of the crowd the lesbian lover of the murdered princess and there are various accounts of what then happened. Some say that Marie Antoinette looked out the window, saw it, screamed and fainted. This seems an exaggeration. The likelihood is that she didn't see it. She wasn't actually there at the time. I think she wasn't in the room. Right.
发生了，故事是这样的：她的头被插在长矛上，带到了监狱——关押王室成员的圣殿堡监狱，当然还有玛丽·安托瓦内特，这位被谋杀的亲王妃的朋友，在群众看来也是她的女同性恋情人。关于接下来发生的事情有各种各样的记述。有人说玛丽·安托瓦内特向窗外望去，看到了这一幕，尖叫并昏厥了过去。这似乎是一种夸张。可能性是她根本没看到。她当时其实不在房间里。我想她不在房间里。对的。
There's a story that the governor's, the prison's wife sees it and faints and people thought that was Mary and Trinette. I think it's possible they put the head on the pike, by the way, to the temple of prison. I think that sounds like something they might have done. Yeah, I agree. And I think that as we'll probably explore later in the episode, it's partly because parading heads on pikes has become a part of revolutionary justice. So the beheading of enemies of the revolution, the parading of their heads, this is part of the language of justice on the streets. So you would almost expect that to happen.
有个故事说，监狱长的妻子看到了这一幕并昏厥了，人们以为那是玛丽·安托瓦内特。我认为他们把头插在长矛上带到圣殿堡监狱是完全可能的。我觉得这听起来像是他们会做的事。是的，我同意。而且我认为，正如我们可能在本集后面探讨的那样，这部分是因为将头颅插在长矛上游街已经成为革命正义的一部分。因此，对革命敌人的斩首，将其头颅游街示众，这是街头正义语言的一部分。所以你几乎会预料到这种事会发生。
There's also a terrible story about the Duke of Orléans, isn't there, as was, who's now become Philippe Egalité. One of the worst people who's ever lived. But again, I don't believe this story. There was a story that he's at the Palais Royal and he's having dinner with some English friends, English guests, and somebody brings in the heads and he looks at him and he says, oh, that's Lombard. I know her by her long hair.
关于奥尔良公爵（也就是现在的菲利普·埃加利特），还有一个可怕的故事，不是吗？他是世上有史以来最糟糕的人之一。但同样，我不相信这个故事。有个故事说他在巴黎皇家宫殿，正和一些英国朋友、英国客人吃晚餐，有人把头颅端了进来，他看着它们说：“哦，那是朗巴勒。我认得出她长长的头发。”
Anyway, let's have dinner. Again, I don't think that happened. I think he's such a terrible man that I'd like to believe it did happen. It reflects very badly on him. I mean, the question of whether the stories are true and won't go into all the details, but there is one particularly notorious account of what happened that I'm going to quote and anyone listening who maybe has children or who doesn't want to hear it, just block out the next couple of minutes. But this is a detail that was reported by a playwright. And again, it's
不管怎样，我们吃晚餐吧。同样，我不认为这发生过。我觉得他是个如此糟糕的人，以至于我很愿意相信它发生过。这极大地败坏了他的名誉。我的意思是，关于这些故事是否真实的问题，我们不会涉及所有细节，但有一个特别臭名昭著的关于所发生事情的叙述，我要引用一下，任何在听节目的人，可能带着孩子或者不想听的，直接屏蔽接下来的几分钟。但这是一个由剧作家报道的细节。同样，
intriguing how often playwrights and fiction writers crop up in these stories. He'd been sympathetic to the revolution, but seven years on when he wrote this, he turned radically against it to become a counter-revolutionary. He's a man called Louis-Sebastien Mercier. And he wrote, when the Princess de l'Ombare was mutilated in a hundred different ways, so already there we have the escalation of the kind of torture porn if you like, and the murderers had partaken of the bleeding morsels of her corpse. So he's saying they're eating her. I mean, the charge of cannibalism there is being overt. One of the monsters cut off her virginal part and made it into a moustache.
剧作家和小说家在这些故事中频频出现，这很耐人寻味。他曾对革命抱有同情，但在七年后他写下这段文字时，他已经彻底转向反对革命，成了一个反革命分子。他是一个名叫路易-塞巴斯蒂安·梅西埃的人。他写道：“当朗巴勒亲王妃以一百种不同的方式被残害时”——所以这里我们已经看到了所谓酷刑色情内容的升级，“凶手们吃掉了她尸体上带血的碎块。”所以他在说他们在吃她食人。我的意思是，食人的指控在这里是公开的。其中一个怪物割下了她的处女部位，并把它做成了胡子。
And the reason for quoting this specifically, partly it reflects the way in which counter-revolutionaries are drawing on the kind of the libertine pornography of which the Marquis de Sade is the exemplar. But it also, I think, points to one of the ways in which the September massacres will be understood and have been understood, which is as an efflorescence of literal demons from hell, monsters who have lost all trace of humanity and can perpetrate the most revolting atrocities. And this will be a way in which, in the wake of the revolution, throughout the 19th into the 20th century, counter-revolutionary traditions in France and beyond will interpret the September Massacres as being not a kind of clinical, patient, methodical elimination of people who they
专门引用这一点的原因，部分是因为它反映了反革命分子正在借鉴恶魔萨德侯爵作为代表的自由主义色情文学。但我也认为，它指出了理解九月大屠杀的一种方式，并且一直以来都是这样被理解的：它就像是地狱中真正的恶魔的怒放，是一群失去了所有人性痕迹、能够犯下最令人作呕的暴行的怪物。这也是在革命之后，整个19世纪到20世纪，法国及其他地区的反革命传统将九月大屠杀解释为一种并非对他们
see as criminals, but as an orgy of destruction and murder. Yeah. Like the stuff of a Gilray cartoon. Yes, exactly. So my take on this is these stories are incredibly controversial among historians and as we will see, because we'll get into that little while, my view is a lot of these stories are clearly made up, you know, the stories of the most grotesque torture, the stories of cannibalism, people drinking
视为罪犯的人进行临床式的、耐心的、有条不紊的清除，而是一场毁灭与谋杀的狂欢。是的。就像吉尔雷漫画里的素材。是的，完全如此。所以我对这件事的看法是：这些故事在历史学家中极具争议，正如我们将要看到的——因为我们稍后会深入探讨——我的观点是，许多这些故事显然是编造的，你知道的，那些最怪诞的酷刑故事、食人故事、人们饮用
blood, all of that kind of stuff. It's part of a tradition of kind of political invective to invent these stories, but I think it's implausible to imagine that a thousand people were killed without, as it were, people overstepping the mark, you know, without mutilation, without rape, because there were suggestions that some of the prostitutes, for example, were abused or raped. Is that inherently implausible? No, I think a lot of these, these are horrific killing.
鲜血的故事，所有这些类别的故事。这属于政治谩骂传统的一部分，即虚构这些故事，但我认为，想象一千人被杀却没有出现越轨行为、没有发生残害、没有发生强奸是不可信的，因为有迹象表明，例如，一些妓女受到了虐待或强奸。这本身就不可信吗？不，我认为其中很多都是可怕的杀戮。
They're not entirely surgical. However, I do agree with you that a mad frenzy is the wrong way to think about it, that it is pretty clear from a lot of these accounts, like that account that we quoted before the break of that guy who let go, there is a kind of semblance of justice. We know that the killers took these tribunals, that they're not all just sort of dancing around wearing people's body parts as hats or whatever covered in blood, that they are actually trying to take these tribunals quite seriously. We know that the crowds listen to the
它们并不完全是外科手术般的精准。然而，我也同意你的观点，即用“疯狂的狂热”来形容它是错误的，从许多这些记述中可以很清楚地看出——比如我们在中场休息前引用的那个被释放的家伙的记述——这里有一种正义的表象。我们知道，行刑者设立了这些法庭，他们并非全都在那里跳舞、把别人的身体部位当帽子戴或者浑身是血，他们实际上是在努力认真对待这些法庭。我们知道群众在倾听
evidence and we do know that the killings were carried out in silence because so many people talk about it. Yeah, somber, somber. Yeah, solemn atmosphere. I mean, some people have talked about it. They've said it was almost like they were ritualistic killings. There was a kind of, dare I say, Tom, I don't want to give you a massive gift, but it's kind of sacral dimension to it. That it was a purge. It was a kind of purge of sin. So it's often said, I think correctly, that there is a presaging here of the notion of
证据，我们也知道杀戮是在沉默中进行的，因为有太多人谈到了这一点。是的，阴郁，阴郁。是的，庄严的氛围。我的意思是，有些人谈到过这一点。他们说这几乎就像是仪式性的杀戮。有一种——我敢说吗，汤姆，我不想给你一个巨大的刺激——但其中有一种神圣的维度。这是一场清洗。这是一种罪恶的清洗。所以人们经常说，而且我认为是正确的，这里预示了20世纪极权主义国家（无论是法西斯主义还是共产主义）中那种
cleansing a state of disease that we see in the 20th century totalitarian states, whether it's the fascists or the communists. But I genuinely think it is also drawing on those Christian traditions, because you talked about a Holocaust. A Holocaust is a burnt offering to the gods. That's originally what it was transmuted into a Christian context because these are all happening in abbeys, in convents. And the sense the Inquisitors had that they were doing God's work when they burned the diseased limb of the tree. This is very similar to the language that you were having with the September massacres. And I think that, I mean, I'm sure that there must have been some kind of sexual sadism going on, maybe particularly at the
清洗国家疾病的概念。但我真的认为它也在借鉴那些基督教传统，因为你谈到过大屠杀。大屠杀原本是献给神的烧祭。最初就是这样，后来在基督教语境中演变了，因为这一切都发生在修道院、女修道院里。审判官在焚烧树木生病的枝干时，觉得自己是在替上帝工作。这与你在九月大屠杀中所使用的语言非常相似。并且我认为——我的意思是，我确信当时肯定发生了一些某种程度的性虐待狂，可能特别是在萨尔佩特里埃。
Salpétrier. But just to say on that issue, it's the Salpétrier where the fewest prisoners are killed. I think it's something like 40, did we say 35 to 40? But there are 280 or 90 there. So relatively speaking, I mean, it's not like they're breaking into a prison full of prostitutes and going mad in the way that rakes in a sad novel would. So I think that is for me the most chilling thing about it. It is murder done in the cause of virtue. Oh, I totally agree with that. I think that the people who do it think they're doing the right thing. They think it's a necessary purge. But that is also why it's important for counter-revolutionary propagandists to frame it as pornographic, because that undermines the claim of those who perpetrated these executions to be virtuous.
但仅就这一点而言，在萨尔佩特里埃被杀的囚犯是最少的。我想大概是40人左右，我们刚才说是35到40人吗？但在那里有280到290人。所以相对而言，我的意思是，这并不像他们闯进一个满是妓女的监狱并在色情小说里那种放荡不羁中发疯。所以对我来说，这才是其中最令人不寒而栗的事情。这是以美德之名进行的谋杀。哦，我完全同意这一点。我认为那些这样做的人认为自己在做正确的事。他们认为这是一场必要的清洗。但这也是为什么反革命宣传家将其塑造成色情内容如此重要的原因，因为这削弱了那些实施这些行刑的人标榜自己具有美德的主张。
I think actually the pornographic kind of mode is the one that people instinctively reach for, because it is, Paris is awash with it. I think it's the natural genre to pick. But I think it is natural for those who repudiate the notion that this has anything to do with virtue. Okay, let's just sum up the story. So it takes four days. The massacres in the prisons last for four days. They die down on the morning of the 6th of September. To give you a sense of what Paris looks like, the place is absolutely full of bodies. There are bodies in the streets, there are bodies in the courtyards, there are bodies in the kind of corridors of the prisons. The rest of the prisoners, of course, have been set free. So the prisons are empty and the commune eventually sends in people and says, please scrub them down and wash them with vinegar. Get rid of the stench, get rid of the stains. But in some
我认为实际上色情这种模式是人们本能会伸手去抓的，因为巴黎到处都是这种东西。我认为这是自然而然选择的类型。但我认为，对于那些拒绝“这与美德有任何关系”这一观点的人来说，这也是很自然的。好了，让我们总结一下这个故事。所以它持续了四天。监狱里的大屠杀持续了四天。它们在9月6日早晨平息下来。为了让你对巴黎的面貌有一个概念，这个地方到处都是尸体。街上有尸体，庭院里有尸体，监狱的走廊里也有尸体。当然，其余的囚犯已经被释放了。所以监狱空了，公社最终派人进去说：“请把它们擦洗干净，用醋清洗。摆脱恶臭，除掉血迹。”但在某些
of the prisons, La Force, for example, there's so much blood they can't shift the blood stains. Of course, a Tom Holland would say some of the rooms are stained with blood, but some of them are pristine and perfectly clean. Why not talk about those rooms? Anyway, we're going to answer this in a second, Tom, because we're going to talk about the historiography. There are copycat killings elsewhere in France. So there are 44 people, for example, that are killed in Versailles, a horrendous atrocity
监狱里，例如拉福斯监狱，血迹太多了，以至于他们无法除掉血迹。当然，一个汤姆·霍兰会说，有些房间沾满了血迹，但有些房间却一尘不染、干净极了。为什么不谈谈那些房间呢？无论如何，我们稍后会回答这个问题，汤姆，因为我们将讨论史学。法国其他地方也发生了模仿杀戮。例如，在凡尔赛有44人被杀，这实际上是一场可怕的暴行。
actually. They are lynched, they are beheaded in public and their heads are stuck on the spikes of the palace gates. So probably about a hundred people are killed across France, but then in the next few weeks, things die down and in the future episodes, we'll talk about why that happens, the political transformation in Paris and a very dramatic change on the battlefield, just to move towards a close on the September massacres. One question is what did people in Paris think of them?
他们被私刑处死，在公开场合被斩首，他们的头颅被插在宫殿大门的尖桩上。因此，整个法国大概有有一百人被死，但在接下来的几周里，事情平息下来，在未来的剧集中，我们将讨论为什么会发生这种情况，巴黎的政治变革以及战场上的戏剧性变化，为了给九月大屠杀画上一个句号。一个问题是，巴黎的人民是怎么看待它们的？
And we know people in Paris thought they were fine. They were completely fine. David Andrus, who you've mentioned before, he makes a very good point that Parisians are used to public violence. I mean, you talked about it, Tom, in that excellent episode you did on the guillotine, the hideous rituals of the public executions, the idea of humiliating, degrading and destroying somebody in public. But Dominic, also what we talked about in that episode was how the revolution equates
我们知道巴黎人民认为它们没问题。它们完全没问题。你之前提到过的大卫·安德鲁斯，他提出了一个很好的观点，即巴黎人习惯了公开暴力。我的意思是，汤姆，你在关于吉洛汀的那集精彩节目中谈到过，公开处刑的恐怖仪式，在公开场合羞辱、贬低和摧毁某人的想法。但多米尼克，我们在那一集里讨论的也是革命如何将
itself with humanitarian impulses. And it may seem mad to talk about humanitarian impulses in the context of the September massacres, but I suspect that maybe a majority of the people doing the executions would say that actually they're not kind of publicly tearing people apart with horses or anything like that. They're doing it expeditiously. And the whole tradition of hanging people from lanterns and then parading their heads is seen as revolutionary justice, but is already starting to be phased out. It's clearly a cause of embarrassment for the revolutionary authorities. And that is why exactly as this is going on, the guillotine is starting to be introduced and is becoming more and more the emblem of how criminals should be dispatched. And the September mass
自身与人道主义冲动等同起来。在九月大屠杀的背景下谈论人道主义冲动似乎很疯狂，但我怀疑，也许绝大多数行刑的人会说，实际上他们并没有像用马匹把人公开撕裂那样。他们是在迅速地完成它。而把人挂在路灯上然后游街示众的整个传统被视为革命正义，但已经开始被逐步淘汰了。这显然让革命当局感到尴尬。这就是为什么正当这一切发生时，吉洛汀开始被引入，并越来越多地成为如何处决罪犯的象征。而九月大屠杀
is, I'm sure, must play a key role in that process. That people in the revolutionary authorities think, okay, fine, I mean, it's cruel necessity, but it would be that process that people in the revolutionary authorities think. Okay, fine I mean, it's cruel necessity, but it would be better to do it with the guillotine Well, it's interesting that the papers at the time they're not embarrassed about it at all This is a moderate paper the courrier Francais the people made it their duty to purge the city of all the criminals to prevent a prison breakout that would have fallen on the women and children Moralical paper revolution to. The people took the extreme measure, but the only appropriate one, of forestalling the horrors that were being
无疑在这一过程中扮演了关键角色。革命当局的人认为，好吧，没关系——我的意思是，这是残酷的必要之举，但革命当局的人会采取这种过程。好吧，没关系，这是一种残酷的必要之举，但如果用吉洛汀来做会更好。有趣的是，当时的报纸对此一点也不感到尴尬。这是一份温和派报纸《法国信使报》：“人民把清洗城市中所有罪犯、防止可能殃及妇女和儿童的监狱暴动当成了自己的责任。”道德派报纸《革命报》：“人民采取了极端但唯一适当的措施，以预先阻止正在向他们逼近的恐怖，并不对那些对他们不会心慈手软的人心慈手软。”
prepared against them and of showing no mercy to those who would not have shown any to them. But if you have a machine that can just slice a head off, you don't need courtyards full of peoples with butcher's knives. Of course. I mean, we have diarists, we have letter writers. There's a brilliant example of a guy, a merchant's son, an son and eighteen year old and Peter McPhee's book on the french revolution and he wrote home and he said there has been a horrible massacre he says where you go you see the bloody remains of mutilated bodies in open graves and then in the next line he says. were plotting with the Prussians, we had to do it. And that diarist Rosalie Julien, she said, again, an atrocious necessity. The people terrible in their fury are avenging the crimes of three years of vile treachery.
但如果你有一台能够直接切下头颅的机器，你就不需要满是带着屠夫刀具的人的庭院了。当然。我的意思是，我们有日记作者，我们有书信写作者。在彼得·麦克菲关于法国大革命的书里，有一个非常精彩的例子，讲的是一个商人儿子、一个十八岁的年轻人，他写信回家说发生了一场可怕的大屠杀，他说你在哪里都能看到敞开的坟墓里被肢解的尸体的血腥残骸，而在下一行他又写道：“他们与普鲁士人密谋，我们不得不这么做。”那位日记作者罗莎莉·朱利安说，同样是一场残酷的必要之举。在狂怒中变得可怕的人民正在为三年卑劣背叛的罪行复仇。
And she talks in her diary. She says, people have had their heads cut off. Priests have been eviscerated. But it's the right thing to do, because we had to save France. Now, the thing is, historians have grappled with this ever since, because of course, most historians by and large, I would say, who write about the French Revolution, especially in France, have been sympathetic to the revolution. And here you have an episode, which is for me much more shocking than the terror.
她在日记中写道。她说：“人们的头被砍掉了。神父被开膛破肚。但这是正确的事情，因为我们必须拯救法国。”现在的问题是，历史学家从那以后一直在与这个问题搏斗，因为当然，大多数撰写法国大革命历史的历史学家——尤其是在法国——大体上都对革命抱有同情。而这里你有一个插曲，对我来说，它比恐怖统治更令人震惊。
I mean, the victims in the terror, a lot of them are people involved in politics, players in the games, they're players. These people are often young, very players in the games, they're players. These people are often young, very poor, the criminals, the petty thieves, the women, the prostitutes, the pras delambas. So from the 21st century perspective, I know Theo says, oh, you're always harder on French exponents of violence than you are when the British do it. But I think even with that said, it's hard to contemplate this and to say, oh yeah, they had to go as Theo clearly
我的意思是，在恐怖统治中，许多受害者是参与政治的人、博弈中的玩家，他们是玩家。而这些人往往很年轻、非常贫困，他们是罪犯、小偷小摸者、妇女、妓女、朗巴勒亲王妃。所以从21世纪的视角来看——我知道西奥说：“哦，你们对法国的暴力行为总是比英国人这样做时更严厉。”——但即使这样说了，也很难面对这一切并说：“哦，是的，他们活该去死”，正如西奥显然所认为的那样。
thinks. You're being a bit harsh on Theo there. You say that it's not comparable to the terror. I mean, lots of innocent people die in the terror. And the difference is that death by the guillotine is more clinical than being hacked to death by people armed with knives and choppers. Don't you think? I suppose so. I mean, I probably would choose the guillotine over being hacked to death by people armed with knives and choppers. Don't you think? I suppose so. I mean, I probably would choose the guillotine over being hacked to death by a carpenter
你在西奥身上有点太严厉了。你说这不能与恐怖统治相比。我的意思是，许多无辜的人死于恐怖统治。不同之处在于，死于吉洛汀比被手持刀具和切肉刀的人砍死要更像临床手术般干净利落。你不觉得吗？我想是的。我的意思是，我可能宁愿选择吉洛汀，也不愿被一个手持锯子的木匠
with a saw. At one o'clock in the morning. Yeah. So the definitive French historian of this was a guy called Pierre Caron and he was writing in the 1930s. He was the head of the National Archives in France. And he said, you have to understand it in the context of two things. One, the fighting at the Tuileries and the thirst for vengeance.
在凌晨一点砍死。是的。所以对此进行过权威研究的法国历史学家是一个名叫皮埃尔·卡隆的人，他在20世纪30年代写作。他是法国国家档案馆的馆长。他说，你必须从两件事的背景下去理解它：第一，杜伊勒里宫的战斗和对复仇的渴望；
And the other is the mood of panic and hysteria as the Prussians advanced on the Capitol and that you have to understand the war, the pressure and all of this kind of thing. And Carol, for years, everybody said he's the top man in the September massacres. He knows what's what. And then 50 years later, our old friend Simon Sharma wrote his book Citizens. Have you read the passage where he talks about Caron? I have. He says his book is, and I quote, a monument of intellectual cowardice and moral self-delusion. And he said, Caron is being far too kind. This is basically anticipating the
第二，随着普鲁士人逼近首都时的恐慌和歇斯底里情绪，你必须理解战争、普鲁士和所有这些类别的因素。并且卡隆多年来，每个人都说他是九月大屠杀的顶级权威。他知道事情的真相。然后50年后，我们的老朋友西蒙·沙马写了他的书《公民》。你读过他谈论卡隆的那段话吗？我读过。他说他的书是——我引用——“一座知识上的懦弱和道德上的自我欺骗的丰碑”。他说卡隆太宽容了。这基本上是在预示
genocides of the 20th century, the same themes we have to get them before they get us, the same emphasis on a kind of what Sharma calls an armed sanitation, on purging France of crime and sin. And you can see why Sharma writing in the 1980s, very conscious of what had happened in Europe 40 years earlier, why he looks at September Mass september ask us to say don't make excuses for this this is. Unbelievably horrible and bestial and he doesn't deny that there's a kind of efficiency and a clinical nature to it but he says that's what makes it all the more frightening but equally he literally is repeating. But equally, he literally is repeating counter-revolutionary propaganda. So to quote him from Citizens when he's writing about Carole, some accounts, including that of Mercier, so that's the playwright,
20世纪的种族灭绝，我们拥有相同的主题：在他们对付我们之前先对付他们，同样强调沙马所谓的“武装净化”，即清洗法国的犯罪和罪恶。你可以理解为什么在20世纪80年代写作的沙马，对40年前欧洲发生的事情记忆犹新，他为什么会看待九月大屠杀并说：不要为这寻找借口，这是令人难以置信的恐怖和野蛮。他并不否认其中存在某种效率和临床性质，但他认为这让它更加可怕，但同样地，他实际上是在重复反革命的宣传。所以引用他在《公民》中关于卡隆的写作：“一些记述，包括梅西埃的记述——也就是那位剧作家的记述，
whose account of the fate of the Princess de Lombard we quoted, insist on the obscene mutilation and the display of her genitals, a story which Carole dismisses with the cloistered certainty of the archivist as intrinsically inconceivable. But we know that didn't happen. And we know that because of research that has happened since he wrote Citizen. So French historian Antoine de Bac, he's the guy who went through all the records of the sections and found that the body of the Princess de l'Ambal was given to the notary of the local section. And he recorded
我们引用过他关于朗巴勒亲王妃命运的记述——坚称存在对她生殖器的淫秽肢解和展示，卡隆带着档案管理员那种与世隔绝的确定性，将这个故事作为‘本质上不可想象的’而予以驳回。”但我们知道那确实发生了。而且我们之所以知道，是因为在他写完《公民》之后进行的研究所揭示的。所以法国历史学家安托瓦内·德·巴克，就是那个翻遍了所有区档案并发现朗巴勒亲王妃的尸体被交给了当地区公所公证人的人。他记录了
what had happened and none of these mutilations had happened. So we know for a fact that that is counter-revolutionary propaganda and that when Caron dismisses it, it's not because he's some cloistered archivist, but because actually he's right about that. That wasn't happening. So in this case, I agree with you, it didn't happen. The thing is, do you take all the revolutionary sources on trust and say the counter-revolutionary ones are propagandistic exaggerations? Or do you say that the truth probably lies in between the two and that both of them are party-pre and actually the truth is that we'll never really know and this is the frustrating
发生了什么，而所有这些残肢虐杀事件根本没有发生。所以我们确凿地知道，那是反革命宣传，当卡隆对此不屑一顾时，并不是因为他是什么隐世的档案管理员，而是因为他在这一点上确实是正确的。那并没有发生。所以在这一点上，我同意你的看法，它确实没有发生。问题是，你是否把所有的革命史料都奉为信条，而认为反革命史料都是夸大其词的宣传？还是说，你认为真相可能介于两者之间，双方都有党派偏见，而实际上真相是我们永远无法真正了解，而这也是令人沮丧的
thing about this story. It's a classic example of historians projecting onto it their own political preconception. So you give these, we talked about David Andrus. David Andrus is very much a man of the left. In his book on the terror, you know, he says the September massacres are terrible, but then in the next breath he has a sentence like this. This is why he introduces the September massacres. The people in arms exercised their right of self-defense against those they felt were
这个故事的地方。这是一个历史学家将他们自己的政治先入之见投射到其中的经典例子。所以你看这些，我们谈到了大卫·安德烈斯。大卫·安德烈斯非常带有左翼色彩。在他的关于恐怖统治的书里，你知道，他说九月大屠杀是可怕的，但在转折的下一句中他却写了这样一句话。这就是他引述九月大屠杀的原因。武装的人民行使了自卫权，去对付那些他们觉得是
betraying them to the counter revolution. You cannot imagine Simon Sharma writing that sentence, can you? No, you can't. But I think that's slightly to misrepresent what he's saying. I mean, he is saying that that is precisely the horror. You know, they think that they're doing justice and that is precisely why it is terrifying. You know, he's saying, I guess in the way that a Christian would say about what the Inquisition did, and I think that there is an absolute continuity there, as I've said, that it's the realization that you can launch a pogrom, execute people in cold blood and feel that you are doing it in the cause of what is right. That's what's frightening.
在向反革命背叛他们的人。你无法想象西蒙·沙玛会写出那样一句话，对吧？不，你不能。但我认为这在某种程度上曲解了他的意思。我的意思是，他是在说，这恰恰是恐怖之处。你知道，他们认为自己在主持正义，而这恰恰就是它令人恐怖的原因。你知道，他在说，我想就像一个基督徒会谈论宗教裁判所做的事一样，我认为这里面存在着绝对的延续性，正如我所说的那样，那就是意识到你可以发动一场大屠杀，冷血地处决人们，并且觉得你是在为正义事业而做这件事。这就是可怕的地方。
Yeah. But I don't think that excuses it. I think that makes it all the more terrifying. No, but I don't think David Andress thinks that either. I mean, I think that I'm no expert in the historiography of the French Revolution, but the reading I've done of writers who are on the left about this is that they do acknowledge that that is what is frightening. You can commit atrocities and feel that you're doing it in the cause of right. And as I say, it's like a Christian having to face up to the executions that have been done in the name of Christ. Well, are you not the person who did an episode about how the Nazis thought what they were
是的。但我不认为这可以作为借口。我认为这让它更加可怕。不，但我不认为大卫·安德烈斯也是这么想的。我的意思是，我认为我并非法国大革命史学方面的专家，但我读过的左翼作家的相关作品表明，他们的确承认这正是可怕之处。你可以犯下暴行，却觉得你是在为正义的事业而做这件事。正如我所说，这就像一个基督徒不得不直面以基督之名进行的处决一样。好吧，你难道不是那个制作过一集节目的节目主持人吗，内容是关于纳粹如何认为他们所做的事情是
doing was right and they were on the right side of history and on the right side of kind of morality? Yes. And that's where the analogy, I suppose Sharma's point about the sanitation kicks in. It's absolutely the right one. So there's another brilliant book on the French Revolution, the most recent English language survey. It's by a guy called Jeremy Popke, an American historian, professor at the University of Kentucky.
正确的，他们站在历史的正确一边以及某种道德的正确一边？是的。我想，这就是沙玛关于美化（洗白）的观点发挥作用的地方。这绝对是恰当的比喻。所以，关于法国大革命还有另一本精彩的书，即最近的英语综合概述。作者是一个叫杰里米·波普金的人，他是美国历史学家、肯塔基大学教授。
And he is much more positive about the revolution than Sharma is. And he says in his section on this, he says, listen, if you think the French Revolution is better than the experiments of the 20th century, for example, communism, or indeed Nazism. If you think the French Revolution is more progressive, as he clearly does, he says you should have a massive problem with the September massacres, because he says the thing that is so frightening about them is that they are so cold-bloodedly political, that they are people sitting down in committee rooms and saying,
他对革命的评价比沙玛更为积极。他在这一章节中指出，听着，如果你认为法国大革命比20世纪的试验（例如共产主义，甚至是纳粹主义）更好。如果你认为法国大革命更加进步（他显然是这么认为的），他说你应该对九月大屠杀感到巨大的困扰，因为他说，这些事件最可怕的地方在于它们是如此冷血地具有政治性，是人们坐在会议室里说，
yeah, these people have got to go, go ahead and do it. Somebody organized the death squads. I mean, of course they were bottom up to some degree, but there were people who led them. There were people who condoned it. There were people who didn't intervene, all of that kind of thing. And his version, and indeed in Timothy Tackett and other historians, they say this is a key step towards what we call the reign of terror. You know, the idea that you maybe you'll make some mistakes and some innocent
是的，这些人必须得走，放手去干吧。有人组织了行刑队。我的意思是，当然它们在某种程度上是自下而上的，但确实有人领导了它们。有人默许了它们。有人没有进行干预，诸如此类的事情。他的版本，以及蒂莫西·塔凯特和其他历史学家，都认为这是迈向我们所谓的恐怖统治的关键一步。你知道，这种想法是，也许你会犯一些错误，一些无辜的
people will be rounded up and killed accidentally, but it's actually better to purge than to allow the evil as they see it to fester in your midst. I agree. And that is, I think think what is frightening about it but I think that historians of all political persuasions would now see that as being what's frightening about it I think. Well because obviously we're gonna be talking about this an awful lot when we get the terror itself but let's not get ahead of ourselves. The elections to the National Convention have been happening all this time and all the big names are standing. Briceau, Robespierre, Danton, Marat. This new convention is
人们会被抓起来并意外杀害，但实际上清除总比任由邪恶（在他们看来）在你们中间滋生要好。我同意。我想这就是它可怕的地方，但我认为所有政治倾向的历史学家现在都会认为这正是它可怕的地方，我想。嗯，因为很显然，当我们真正谈到恐怖本身时，我们要对这个话题进行大量的讨论，但我们不要操之过急。国民公会的选举一直在进行，所有的大人物都在参选。布里索、罗伯斯庇尔、丹东、马拉。这个新的国民公会
going to meet on the 20th of September and it is going to decide the future of France and in particular something I know you'll be talking about in a couple of episodes time, the future of the royal family. But the question is will this convention even get the chance to do that? Because all this time the Prussians have been coming closer and closer and closer. So Verdun fell, the Duke of Brunswick is coming on, he's got 80,000 men every day, he is coming closer to Paris. He is now being pursued by a smaller French army under General de Mourier, who is the foreign minister who got France into the war in the first place.
将于9月20日开会，它将决定法国的未来，特别是正如我所知，你将在接下来的几集节目中讨论的事情——王室的未来。但问题是，这个国民公会甚至能得到这个机会吗？因为一直以来，普鲁士军队越来越近、越来越近。凡尔登沦陷了，不伦瑞克公爵正在逼近，他拥有8万大军，每一天，他都在向巴黎靠近。他现在正遭到一支由迪穆里埃将军率领的较小的法国军队的追击，迪穆里埃就是那个最初将法国卷入战争的外交大臣。
And by the third week in September, the Prussians reach a place called Valmy, which is in the Argonne forest. It's about 120 miles from Paris and rain is falling. The skies are overcast and it's against this very kind of turbulent backdrop that the Duke of Brunswick and the Prussians turn to finish off the French and to clear the battlefield for their final assault on the capital. And Tom, what happens next will change the course of European history. Thank you, Dominic. Brilliant. What a cliffhanger. So much more to come. Lots more drama. And of course, if you are a member of the Rest is History Club, you can listen to the
到了9月的第三周，普鲁士军队到达了一个叫做瓦尔my的地方，它位于阿贡森林。距离巴黎大约120英里，雨正在下。天空阴沉，正是在这种非常动荡的背景下，不伦瑞克公爵和普鲁士人转过身来，准备彻底消灭法军，并为他们对首都的最后进攻清理战场。汤姆，接下来发生的事情将改变欧洲历史的进程。谢谢你，多米尼克。太精彩了。真是个悬念迭起。还有更多精彩内容。还有很多戏剧性事件。当然，如果你是“历史的休憩”俱乐部的会员，你可以收听
next three episodes of this epic journey to the climax of the French Revolution right now. We will be discussing in our next episode, Olympe de Gouges, the first feminist, the author of The Rights of Woman. We will be discussing the fall of the French monarchy and the climax will be the guillotining of Louis XVI. So it's one of the great stories not just of French history but of history full stop and if you're not a member of the Restless History Club then you can listen to the next episode on Olymp de Gouges this coming Thursday. Thank you so much for listening. Goodbye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这场通往法国大革命高潮的史诗般旅程的接下来三集节目。我们将在下一集中讨论奥兰普·德古热，第一位女权主义者，《妇女权利宣言》的作者。我们将讨论法国君主制的垮台，而高潮将是路易十六被送上断头台。所以这不仅是法国历史上伟大的故事之一，也是整个历史中伟大的故事之一，如果你不是“历史的休憩”俱乐部会员，那么你可以在本周四收听关于奥兰普·德古热的下一集节目。非常感谢您的收听。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。